so back in 2015 there was a game dying
light that came out and i remember at
that time there wasn't a lot that i
particularly wanted to play so i tried
it out and i really enjoyed it i
actually have said multiple times on
multiple different outlets that i
consider dying light the best zombie
game that's ever made and i've been
looking forward to dying light 2 for the
longest time and i'm proud to say that i
have played dying light 2 and you are
watching the dying light 2 review from
lord addict on the xbox series x and
before we get on with the review
definitely subscribe to the channel if
you enjoyed it we have weekly podcasts
every 1pm on sundays called the
ironlords podcast don't forget to go
there and follow me at twitter at lord
addict iop without any further ado
here's my review on dying light 2.
[Music]
there for many years i felt like zombie
games was just everywhere you couldn't
get away from zombie games from dying
light to stay decay and you had dead
rising i don't know if you would
technically consider last of us a zombie
game because i know that's kind of more
of like a plant-like if i remember
correctly but i would say that i would
put that in the same genre just maybe
not the same exact thing as it comes to
zombie but the point of the matter is i
felt like these games was really pushing
the envelope and nothing was doing it
anything special and for the longest
time i've been waiting for dying light 2
because it's something that i really
enjoyed when i played the first one and
i felt like it came up short when it
came to a lot of other people and i was
really anticipating teclan getting a
second shot to really wow people so
let's start the first thing you see when
you boot up dying light 2 it's that
graphics what the game looks like and i
could actually firmly say that it's a
huge step up from the first one i
actually thought dying light one looked
pretty good but they definitely hit it
out of the park in terms of graphics for
dying light too what i really always
enjoyed about dying light is just the
intensity that the map gives the game
play because when you go out at night
everything is just way extra and it's
just like that with the sound man you
guys gotta really take in when you play
this game and you're in these very dark
areas at night and the sound of the
zombies just screaming sometimes you'll
be in buildings and you'll just hear
random screams for no reason i do feel
like that's a little bit too much
sometimes because there will be
incidences where i feel like it's just
in the walls and they don't really
intend on you finding the source to the
sound they just want to really amplify
the intensity of that moment with the
sound and i don't really like that too
much i feel like if you do that again
just make sure that there's a source to
it there was a couple times where i
actually looked for what was screaming
and i could not find it but maybe that
was just me and my impatient self
couldn't find it because you know that's
how i am man i'm not going to sit there
and look too long i get my interest my
curiosity goes off i look for it if i
can't find it i just dip because that's
just the person i am i think a lot of
you are gonna really appreciate the
different type of parts of the map now
there isn't really necessarily like a
snowy part of the map or anything like
that for the most part everything's
identical but there are parts of the map
that's hazardous that just look really
nice on the eyes especially when it
comes off the sun there's a lot of
incidences where there'll be a lot of
explosions and stuff going on and you
see the clear damage that it's doing to
the city and there'll be smoke
everywhere i feel like they did really
good job with this now as far as saying
it's like next-gen level obviously this
is a previous gen game so you can't
really say it's a next-gen level i do
feel like it's definitely above average
in terms of graphics but i wouldn't go
above and say this is extremely good on
the eyes it's just a nice looking game
and i think it passes that part for me
at least on to the story dying light 2
doesn't have a phenomenal story it's
it's kind of an average you can tell
exactly what's going to happen there's
nothing really defining about this story
i wouldn't say there's going to be any
part of this that makes people feel like
it is above average in terms of
storytelling but one thing dying light 2
does well is the characters in the game
sure there are a lot of incidences where
i felt like the main character was
lacking and they could have done a lot
better in terms of building that
character to where you actually
understood his concerns like i knew what
was going on with the main character but
i didn't exactly agree with how they
carried it how they executed it like i
could sense the emotion in the main
character but it never felt to the point
where i'm like man i sympathize with
them i feel bad for them i've kind of
felt that way more towards the other
characters of the game i think they did
them extremely well when you come across
some of these characters i found myself
sympathizing with the side characters
and the other people that's not the main
character more than i did the main
character and the funny thing about the
story is dying like two kind of takes
place on one of those i gotta rescue
someone and that's what pretty much the
whole story is about is the main
character rescuing a certain person and
i found myself caring more about the
scenarios that these other people are in
more than actually looking for the
person that the main character wanted to
look for and i think that's that's a
really good thing of doing writing wise
and when it comes to certain choices in
the game i wasn't even really caring
about that person i was like what is it
going to affect the people that i like
sure it might not necessarily be the
main character because i didn't really
feel like they did a lot in terms of
executing me sympathizing with him like
i said and i didn't really care about
his struggles i care more about the
people he's helping and i think that's a
funny thing and i've not really
experienced that too many times in game
but you know take that how you feel i do
feel like that might be a double-edged
sword and i i don't know exactly how you
guys will take that i don't want to act
like the main character is blane and
he's not interesting he is an
interesting character but i feel like
compared to the rest of the game he
falls short now you guys know gameplay
is my all-time favorite when it comes to
attributes on an actual game i feel like
the story is important and the graphics
of the game is important but when it
comes to that gameplay that gameplay
isn't fun i'm not going to care about
the other ones i'm happy to say that
dying light 2 hits that out of the park
you have two huge decent sized areas to
have be a playground of your parkourness
and what i mean by that is this is one
of the very few games that i do feel
like is a dying light 2 moment kind of
game where there are scenarios that
happen in this game where after you do
it you're like man that can only happen
in dying light and i've really enjoyed
that they do kind of bit off a little
bit of ubisoft mechanics now i can't
remember exactly if these were in dying
light one because it's been so long
since i played it but they got that
standard we're gonna climb something
inactivated thing now now that's not
really necessarily saying anything bad
about it but i for one am tired of those
type of mechanics and i would like to go
away from them and find more unique ways
of filling out a map than just climbing
something and activating something but i
guess until we find a better way as an
industry we're going to be dealing with
these wack buildings or whack towers
that we have to climb and it's like i
said it's not necessarily saying it's
bad it's just come on man let's find
something better all right let's talk
about the character development you got
a pre-set up character you can't really
make anything there's not like any kind
of character customization where you can
make the main character any way you want
the main character's name is aidan and
he looks that way regardless but what
you can do is get certain abilities to
make him unique you have a tree with
fighting in a tree with parkour and let
me tell you guys something the parkour
tree was great and there was a lot of
times where i was actually debating what
tree i wanted to invest to at that
moment because what dying light 2 does
well is it makes it to where you do have
to fight at certain points and you
really want to invest in a parkouring at
certain point there will be certain
parts of the map that you have to do
that's story related to where there's
multiple ways of doing it and if you
have a better parkour tree you can do it
a lot easier than if you would have just
invested into combat you might have to
climb more stuff or it sometimes put
yourself in really intense situations
and hope that you don't fall to your
death because you didn't invest into
that parkour tree system at the
beginning of this game the fighting
system's pretty blane and it's pretty
basic but once you upgrade that combat
system a good amount there is a lot of
perks that make it more fluid you'll
seem to enjoy it a lot more now i will
say at the beginning i was more about
running from situations they're not
necessarily fighting but once you unlock
a good amount of those upgrade skills
you feel more in control of your
character during a fight and the
interesting part is they actually have
multiple kind of playing styles so if
your play style is more of getting in
your face cutting zombies heads off or
you know just pretty much running from
everything you can do that i like a lot
of the objects and stuff that they have
in this game they have infected knives
that when you throw them at actual
people they will turn into infected and
that's really unique because what you
can do is if you don't want a lot of
conflict at a certain situation because
there's a lot of people there you can
throw one of these infected knives or an
infected arrow it would turn them and
they'll actually turn on the other
people there and you can use that to
take out bigger targets that are a lot
more hard for you as a character to take
them down and i think that's interesting
not to mention there's actually more
infected there's a lot more emphasis on
running at night i feel like the night
gameplay on this is a lot better than it
was in dying light one but i do feel
like it needed to be more intense than
it was in this game and what i mean by
that is i want dying lights night
gameplay because that's supposed to be
the most dangerous time to play dying
light and i feel like that's what
separates it from other zombie type like
games and i don't think that they go too
i don't think they go as far i'm going
to be real with you guys i feel like
what they need to do is it needs to be
one of those things where it doesn't
matter if you're on the rooftops it
doesn't matter if you're running through
the streets these zombies will come
after you now they do have incidences
where if you come across certain key
point zombies they will initiate what
called a chase and it's pretty much just
someone one of the zombies screaming and
it's alerting the rest of the zombies
that you're there but the thing is is i
never one time in this game felt like i
was in danger at night sure i would die
occasionally on this game and i died a
lot in terms of judging a fall and not
judging it correctly and i would die
from fall damage i never really died too
many times on actual zombies and i feel
like considering this is a zombie game
i'm tired of these companies not putting
enough fear on the zombies it kind of
feels like that point in the walking
dead where zombies is like a real key
point at the beginning of the series but
then when you get closer to the end of
the series or later on in the show it
turns out that zombies isn't the main
problem it's humans and i feel like
you're going to embrace that the
majority of the time in a zombie
apocalypse thing but i felt like you
could do both you don't have to do just
one you can make the zombies aggressive
you can make the zombies more effective
and more scary and you can also make the
humans be the divining pathetic
creatures that they are at some points
of the game you could easily do both and
i and i always felt like especially in
dying light 2 when you get more of these
abilities the zombies aren't even an
issue anymore you could run from the
majority of them and i want that to
change i felt like you know when a
zombie grabs you it should be a rat but
it's not like that it's you know for the
most part you can have abilities where
you can jump on the zombies to get more
of the air you can get on the rooftops
relatively easy now there are zombies on
the rooftops but there's not a lot so as
long as you stick on the roofs you'll be
fine they're for the most part are never
gonna get to you up there now if you
initiate a chase and you run on the
rooftops they will most definitely chase
you anywhere you go but to be honest
with you guys even the chases are not
that bad because when you do outpost you
get these uv lights that's on the actual
outpost and for the most part if you run
into a chase or you initiate a chase
it's literally just you either bringing
up the map and finding the next outpost
it's nearest to you which sometimes can
be a bother especially if you're on the
ground and you activate one of these
because that means a lot of the times
you're going to be climbing a lot of
stuff and keep in mind these zombies
will climb with you and some of them are
actually faster than you so you can't
just straight up bolt and get away from
them but i feel like it was defeated for
the most part because sometimes you
would have to go to these weird
positions to get to uv light but as you
unlock more faction buildings and as you
unlock more outposts it was literally
just looking around finding one
relatively close and getting to it and
the chase would be ended
almost immediately when you got into the
uv light i feel like they could have
handled that better maybe depending on
the power level of the actual zombies i
do feel like they should be able to
overpower the uv lights if there's a
bunch of them and kill everybody in that
settlement you have to re-establish that
settlement or have some kind of
consequences for initiating chases that
you can easily get rid of now i want to
say that this game marketed a lot of
special features in it to where if you
side with a certain faction you have a
certain outcome and i'm not saying that
they didn't kind of false advertise it
but i am saying that it's not as a big
difference as a lot of you would like i
felt like for the most part it might
change some dialogue but it doesn't
change anything drastically in terms of
how the world is built maybe it will
change the ending because i only beat
the game one time i didn't really
experiment a lot with beating the game
multiple times but the time i did beat
it i did like the way the story played
out in the way the story was changing on
my on my actual decisions but i felt
like the world itself wasn't really
evolving too much what i do like is
there will be certain buildings that are
key components in the world map and when
you take them over you can assign it to
neither the peacekeepers or the
survivors and every time you do this
because there's a good ten times you
could do this on each side they'll give
you a bonus perk to being on that side
and i really enjoyed that because if you
went to the survivors the way i went it
kind of went more towards the parkour
system and i felt like if you went
towards the peacekeepers and went more
towards surviving at night and the
reason i went for the survivor trees
because i personally feel like the night
system in this game is flawed and you
could easily stay alive so it wasn't
really one of those incidences where i
was ever fearful that i needed any kind
of perks to stay alive and i don't want
to come out like really harsh in terms
of how they did the faction system in
this game but what i would see faction
system i see like fallout new vegas to
where when you mess with one faction
that doesn't like that faction their
enemies are your enemies and i never got
that in this game i wanted it to be
where if i paired with their enemy not
necessarily their enemy they don't
really ever come out openly said they
got beef with each other but pairing
with one side and siding with one side
is going to naturally make the other
side mad and i've always wanted that
incidence where when i played fallout
new vegas and i came across a faction
that i have consistently ignored and did
by them wrong i wanted that faction to
be kind of it's on site where if you go
across those at all they're on you and i
never felt that in dying like two and
that's something they definitely could
improve on maybe in a patch or maybe you
know whenever they do another one maybe
20 28 the way it took to do dying like
two i'm not saying that it's like a huge
minus but i will say that that's
something that i personally was
disappointed with but as far as the
faction system in terms of story like i
did like how they do that but it's just
the world building i wanted to change
but the key factor in dying light 2 and
i think the biggest thing that they
always advertise when it comes to
playing this game is this it's a
survival zombie apocalypse that you can
parkour anywhere you want to go and it
does that effectively does that very
well i feel like when you max out or
close to max out that parkour tree
system anything is a goal you could do
anything you want to do if you feel like
an objective is too hard to climb you
could climb that it's just how you want
to do it and whether or not that skill
tree is up to par with the complications
that you're putting in place to do it
and i really enjoyed that you know
techland really does this well that i
don't really see a lot of other
developers effectively doing in 2022 and
that's the movement of the character and
besides spider-man where you felt like
the movement was such a highlight of the
game i can't really tell you another
game where i felt like i had so much
freedom in just how i move around the
map and i gotta really tip my hat off
when it comes to techland and that kind
of scenario now let's talk about the
really really bad this game has a lot of
bugs now i will say that the bugs were
never to the point where i'm just like
i'm done i'm not playing this i'm
uninstalling this game but i will say
when they happen i was annoyed and
there's a lot of incidences where there
was this weird sound that went on it was
kind of audio glitch there was
incidences to where it felt like an
objective wasn't triggered when i did it
so i'd have to reboot the game and do it
again now if you are okay with having a
lot of inconveniences because that's
what i would consider these glitches
inconveniences something like cyberpunk
there was a lot of game breaking stuff
to where it was annoying and you
couldn't really see yourself finish to
the game and that's why i uninstalled
that game but when it comes to dying
light it's a lot of inconveniences in
terms of the the glitches you could
easily play this game the way it is now
but i would recommend you waiting don't
play this game until they have that
patch and fixing it now if you really
enjoyed dying like one and you wanted a
similar experience and you don't want to
wait for the patches it's easily able to
be done you could play this the state
the game's in now like i said but be
prepared to climb towers multiple times
be prepared to get killed because the
mission doesn't accelerate the way it's
supposed to because it glitches and the
game doesn't register you're in places
where you're supposed to be be prepared
to be very annoyed throughout the game
because there are certain scenarios to
where it's just not happening however
like i said even with all these
inconveniences and these glitches that
annoyed me i enjoyed every bit of this
game and i do feel like once they get
these bugs fixed it's going to be worth
the money now whether or not you want to
reward them for releasing a buggy game
which i don't feel like we should reward
them at all i don't blame you for
waiting maybe in the future it comes to
like a subscription service like game
pass or playstation now or maybe just
waiting for this game to be 20 30
cheaper and buying it then because at
the end of the day as much as i am for
devs i don't want to reward bad behavior
and a lot of the times it's not the
developer's fault it's the publisher
that actually funded the project i don't
know if techland funded and published
the game itself i don't know if they
have any backers that's pushing this
game out before it's ready because i do
think that this should have been in the
oven for another six months to really
give us a quality product and i'm pretty
sure the reviews are going to reflect
these glitches because it's like i said
these glitches was an inconvenience to
me i never stopped playing it but i can
see why after about the third or fourth
tower you have to do them twice and some
of these towers are very difficult to
climb on certain scenarios if you don't
have a certain parkour skill and i can
totally see why someone will just drop
the game and say i'm done i've tried it
it's not working but that's just my
opinion on the matter look now if you
guys want to go out there and still play
it just i would recommend googling the
latest patch for dying light 2 and see
if some of these issues that i have put
up have been remedied and have been
fixed and if they have it i would say
wait but if you guys want to jump in
this zombie apocalypse i don't blame you
go ahead and do it but i would recommend
waiting until they're fixed but anyway
tell me what you guys think the comment
section below like i said i think the
graphics are look they look great they
don't nothing special but it's
definitely something that is acceptable
in 2022 i think the gameplay is
fantastic the story is is okay it's not
anything special but it's definitely
something that i enjoyed as it unfolded
and i think that when it comes to if you
should buy dying light 2 you know if you
want to go out there and buy it because
it's something that you really enjoyed
with dying light one and you don't want
to wait then i totally understand but i
would wait i would wait till these bugs
are fixed where you actually have a very
quality product playing there's not a
whole lot of issues while you're booting
it up keep in mind i didn't play this on
the ps5 i didn't play this on the pc i
don't know the conditions of these ports
and i could only speak for my experience
and the issues that i had playing it but
i enjoyed it and until next time this is
lord addict and you just listened and
watched the review of dying light 2
peace